[Music]
and not a good flight news the far part
in that one - submitted by Seymour
booties see my booties Seymour boot is a
regular flight to Miami turned into a
nightmare after an airdrop photo caused
chaos oh [ __ ]
airdrop picture doing that [ __ ] is it
like a dick pictures of bombs - we were
on we were in Europe and then like you
would open up your phone cuz you're
gonna airdrop something to me then you
see everyone else's little icons and
then you would send them funny pictures
of like a monkey with lipstick on yeah I
know you can do this it's amazing I
don't know about that I found that know
one of the joys of it because if people
always have their airdrop on e-470
like everything Sam don't know what's
coming from yeah but they see it but
they see it I see it already
oh that's pretty good yeah they see it
thumbnail and you see people go up and
like we're like yeah what the [ __ ] sent
me this yeah I love it on your phone I
always thank the people that I know
oh but that was my picture Oh true if
they see your dick you have power over
them yes I believe that they saw it now
they can't unsee what they saw that's
right and now I have power over you how
does that work what do you mean how does
that work
you just occupy like three other brain
cells yeah no they're thinking about
your dick even if it's in a bad way
they're thinking about your pigs don't
you saw it and you own part of their
brain yeah but then you're but then
aren't you thinking about them so then
they own you - no absolutely not I'm not
thinking about them at all I'm thinking
about how I control their brain so
you're thinking about okay there was
this flight from Oakland to Maui those
delayed about 90 minutes like the worst
flight ever why why they're going to
Maui or to Maui Maui I was like they
have 90 minutes oh yeah oh yeah said
Mary did you say Miami you did see my
I thought you said Miami no you're
welcome to Maui yeah cuz he said Miami
is in Miami earlier Miami I didn't even
catch that he bits in Miami oh yeah you
said Miami I heard Bali anyway there's
Oakland to Maui and it was delayed about
90 minutes
Maui my second home yeah and it was all
because of this girl she was trying to
airdrop
a photo to her mom but her mom just got
a brand-new phone so it wasn't am I
gonna have a name or anything so she
kept sending it to other people's phones
my next photo
well she was trying to send it to her
mom this photo which I'm like dude you
have her number why don't you just text
it to her anyway
the photo was this is the file press the
file
she needs high quality for this specific
photo because it's a photo of a dead
child facedown in a crime scene why
would she send her that to scare her mom
or something so this photo which I'll
show you right now - of all the things
whoa whoa it's fake just so you guys
know it's funny that makes it
undisturbed this doesn't happen all
right [ __ ] I mean it is a little less I
honestly do better if it's a real real
child but it's still twisted but it's
not as [ __ ] up yeah twisted so she was
trying to send her that image because
it's from her high school medical
biology class so it was like part of her
class and she was trying to share that
with her mom but she ended up sending -
sending it to other people the daughter
she sent it to at least 15 other
passengers what an idiot
that's how many times you have to try
like what I thought I thought I thought
yeah like what a idiot so because of
that reason a lot of passengers were
distressed and so they notified the
flight crew
and that's when they had to remove the
mom and the daughter from the flight and
figure out like is this a real photo
like what is like what is the situation
stupid idiot girl I know so Stephanie
she's lying I'm just trying to scare her
mom but I don't think it has anything to
do with their biology class probably cuz
I probably - yeah that sounds like that
sounds like she was trying to prank her
mom cuz if she really wanted to share
something you don't have to send a
15-times she just walked her mom see and
it's fake so she was trying to it's not
like the caption was like this was a
crazy part of our class with the fake
dummy like she just sent who's she was
sending it to get the shock from her mom
yeah I didn't you'd be like I think
that's why it's airdrop because it'll
pop up on their own instead of yeah 15
times like you knew you were sending
this to other people like that she's
trying to get her mom good I think she's
trying to I'm perfect you think she was
just trying to scare all the other
tricks
yeah she was trying to scare everybody
on the airplane she was trying to do it
punk-ass [ __ ] I would deny - you have
to define if they divert the flight over
it and you're like gonna go maybe get
federal charges or something that's true
I play innocent like a [ __ ] hell
yeah if I was a mom talk be like oh yeah
[ __ ] your [ __ ] when I get home I'll be
so mad but on the airplane I'll be like
oh no that's a science project down hell
yeah I ride on my [ __ ] kids so you
wouldn't really really really for all
that [ __ ] oh good call you good citizen
you have to think like Gemma from
anarchy
I wouldn't even tell she's a gas crisis
is yeah I black I don't know you [ __ ]
read the sign pal what do you see you
tell me what you see yeah well I'm still
gonna discipline the [ __ ] out of her
yeah fun you can only communicate with a
Styrofoam cup and the [ __ ] wire if
you want to talk if that's fun that's
really nice no no every time you talk to
someone you have to talk and do this
that's exciting like they could date
it's gonna be did you ever do it can I
ask you to yeah it's fine it's fun but
didn't you have to do that for the rest
of your like year a whole year you have
to communicate that way you have fun for
a year I don't mind
away I guarantee you I could make the
fun things torturous and then actually
write letters the text mm-hmm it's like
hey guess what no more Xbox just regular
Nintendo and super ninja no no no no no
only tic-tac-toe only tic-tac-toe that's
it great this girl she's 15 years old in
case you guys were wondering her age
so they were taken out of the flight
they were rebooked on another flight she
was questioned by the police but then
they determined that there was no crime
she was crying all that should happen to
those passengers right so then finally
they finally like their plane finally
took off after 90 minutes also that [ __ ]
happened before the flight before Wow
yeah I'm on my way to Hawaii well that's
true because people had to be on Wi-Fi
cuz I was thinking like it was just
everybody on the plane doing Wi-Fi mmm
that could happen to I I discovered that
you don't gonna have service to do our
job this is blue teeth mr. blue tooth
did everybody get to Maui okay so then
when they were on their way to Maui uh
someone illegally brought a pepper spray
can into the flight and it accidentally
leaked oh [ __ ] you're telling me to say
didn't you say they didn't do their job
what a shocker
[ __ ] flying flight repeat like the
same group no offense to TSA people
watching this but dude those [ __ ]
body scanners and [ __ ] they don't do
anything of course it's on the bag it's
oh you know what if it's small they
could mistake it for like a travel size
spray hairspray or whatever yeah hey so
it's spilled and what happened then like
and that happened like towards the front
of the plane so then everyone in the
front they just kept coughing their eyes
are all watery like they couldn't so
there's our first class that's not what
you pay for man you know those people in
the back are like first class is [ __ ]
yeah do they know as prepper sprayers
are just started coffee for no reason
they don't even know what's happening uh
well some people were saying that they
thought it was a terrorist attack like
they were prepared to death
you guys never pay attention to the fact
that this is the second thing that
happened no I love it
what's reacting to that they don't like
you why I think it's crazy I just want
to get to Maui okay have a good time
[ __ ] so they're saying that there are
about 40 people gathered at the back of
the plane trying to breathe isn't that
[ __ ] up the plane oh yeah good point
[ __ ] movie where they were like you
have to like balance certain things I
mean yeah the Aaliyah movie baby cuz
they [ __ ] it overloaded the plane but
it's not gonna be like this they
overloaded the [ __ ] out of that plane
too soon
Aaliyah no you wanna too soon Aaliyah
should have packed way too much luggage
dude that's what happens this is my tell
Vicky every time we fly I'm like you
want to be like Aaliyah
then you go ahead and bring it yeah you
go ahead bringing suitcases to the UK if
you want to be like Aaliyah on the
brighter side at least they land on Maui
cuz it would suck if like you had to go
through all this [ __ ] in a new land
on like the shittiest like Kentucky like
yo pilot can we open a window cuz this
shit's crazy [ __ ] the pilot was on I
told everyone to go to the back and then
so after they landed there were 12
passengers and three front flight
attendants that were treated for
respiratory issues what airline is this
point Hawaiian airline that sucks I love
Hawaiian air that way you know they're
the only domestic flight that offers
like free food as a part of the service
so yeah it's pretty big and breakfast
sandwiches deal with this what hope so I
just can't
I'm nervous is good and everything is I
don't know I just I just feel like so
let's also put it this way if there
wasn't the delay and then like you know
maybe maybe some forces were stopping
that plane from [ __ ] hitting a
hurricane or some [ __ ] or like some kind
of you know maybe it could crash or
something else but thank thank goodness
that 90 minute delay happened because
they survived yeah I wonder what
who say everything happens for a reason
yeah what about like a pepper spraying
game that pepper spray can blowing up
like in the front row of the plane and
like 25 passengers all have to go to the
back and breathe in and out standing up
for four hours like what judges said I
just said maybe that do you think it's
the butterfly effect is out yourself
yeah well like that's just how I live
life because if I don't think that way
then I'll just be pissed at everything
all the time truth so I have to think
like oh I dodged a bullet
yeah or else I can't let it go because I
think I'll just be bitter for the rest
of the day like this [ __ ] [ __ ] had
[ __ ] pepper spray Lincoln out now I
should pepper spray them but how can you
be bitter wouldn't you're on Hawaiian
Airlines isn't that's right feels great
right yes most cuz you yeah I can never
go back
ah it's like floating on air right yeah
it's like floating on a bed yeah sweet
macadamia nut everywhere the oven
drawers it's this and the service is so
Aloha yeah and then the stewardesses
they have coconuts do really you've
never you that's why you're so grumpy
you've never flown why I want that no
actually I did I did Singapore air and
the students were all hot as [ __ ] though
and I was doing there it was doing it
for my ones dope about like Singapore
and a Korean Airlines all the Asian
airlines since they don't really have
tenure if you get ugly they just fire
you [ __ ] too you get better service too
did you get tenure right so we like all
of our flight attendants were like 50
year old comfy old ladies tell me about
there there's no such thing they're not
really PC so you're too ugly you're too
fat get out of here that's like the
Golden Age of hooters yeah winners was
great when Hooters was a majestic place
you could always go and find hot women
now it's like busted ass it's you know
Millennials are going on a tenure I'll
say that lot of tenure they all look
like Supreme Court justices in there oh
[ __ ]
[Music]